[Musique]
propriété du groupe papier excellence
est devenu officiellement propriétaire
de produits forestiers résolus cette
semaine la clôture de l'acquisition de
plus de 3 milliards 500 millions de
dollars canadiens étaient complétés avec
succès le siège social de papier
excellence est en Colombie-Britannique
mais les propriétaires sont des
investisseurs milliardaires d'Indonésie
d'origine chinoise la famille widget
cette famille dans la richesse dépasse
10 milliards de dollars américains
détient un géant mondial du papier et je
ne porte paper on en parle ce soir avec
Robert Beauregard qui est professeur
titulaire elle a Faculté de foresterie
géographie géométrique de l'Université
Laval on sort monsieur Beauregard
est-ce qu'il y a un enjeu stratégique
avoir des entreprises étrangères
asiatiques ou d'origine chinoise dans ce
cas-ci détenir des entreprises de
ressources naturelles comme la forêt
chez nous
c'est sûr que c'est quelque chose de
nouveau dans notre paysage l'industrie
forestière au Canada et au Québec
cette entreprise-là en 2007 n'était pas
présente du tout au Canada puis
aujourd'hui avec l'acquisition de résolu
il devient le plus grand joueur de
l'industrie forestière au Canada et un
des plus grands joueurs en Amérique du
Nord donc c'est une évolution très
rapide et assez surprenante est-ce ils
pourront pas partir avec la ressource
qui les intéresse c'est l'accès aux
ressources naturelles donc
les ressources demeure ici les
compétences sont ici les jobs sont ici
ils vont pas déménager les usines c'est
pas possible
stratégique comme d'autres types de
ressources
non certainement pas c'est pas comme les
métaux stratégiques ou l'énergie il y a
eu certaines transactions qui ont été
qui ont posé question qui ont été
questionnées par le gouvernement fédéral
ces dernières années mais ça sera pas le
cas ici mais l'Asie un grand besoin de
papier hygiénique de papier d'emballage
de ressources en général et ici il y a
une source importante de ces ressources
et c'est sans doute la raison pour
laquelle ils font l'acquisition de ces
grandes entreprises canadiennes et ils
mettent la main aussi sur des droits de
coupe quand on regarde les droits de
coupe au Québec résolu et l'entreprise
qui a le plus de droit de coupe on parle
de 28% des droits de coupe qui sont avec
résolus arbek c'est 14 % les chantiers
de shibugamo c'est 5% et les autres donc
est-ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter que ces
droites coupe finalement soit entre les
mains d'intérêt étrangers
les droits coupe et sont gérés par le
gouvernement du Québec et donc ça
appartiendra au gouvernement du Québec
de gérer la relation contractuelle avec
le détenteur de droits pour respecter
les exigences de bonnes gestion
environnementales et des ressources
naturelles pour que les parce que c'est
un bien public la forêt la grande
majorité de l'approvisionnement de ses
usines vont venir de la forêt public
donc ça sera la responsabilité du
gouvernement du Québec de s'assurer du
respect des ententes contractuels sur
les droits d'approvisionnement et entre
autres sur les enjeux d'environnement on
sait que bientôt le gouvernement du
Québec va déposer un plan pour la
gestion du caribou il y avait déjà une
certaine tension très élue gouvernement
du Québec avec ce nouveau joueur ça va
jouer comment ça sera à suivre de près
ce qu'on a l'assurance puis vous dites
bon la ressource est ici ils viennent
ici ils veulent l'exploiter ici la
ressource ils peuvent pas déménager les
forêts en quelque sorte mais ce qu'on a
quand même l'assurance que ça va qu'on
va protéger l'entreprise qu'on va
protéger des emplois puisqu'on va
protéger aussi le siège social ou le
bureau principal de Montréal
je pense que le
personnel de gestion au siège social à
Montréal de résolu à tout le monde à une
réputation de grandes compétences pour
la gestion d'une entreprise de cette
taille-là et de cette complexité-là ils
l'ont démontré dans les dernières années
il faut se souvenir que résolu passer à
travers la loi de protection de la
faillite c'était à Bixby boater qui
valait plus rien pratiquement il y a
quelques années à peine et qui puisse
faire l'objet d'une transaction de trois
points 5 milliards aujourd'hui c'est
quand même assez c'est la preuve qu'il y
a eu une bonne gestion ces dernières
années et aussi que les marchés se sont
redressés bien sûr mais donc il y a une
bonne gestion qui est reconnue à
Montréal mais bien sûr c'est Franck
d'autori qui disait en décembre dernier
quand le propriétaire est en Asie c'est
très loin et parfois quand il y a des
décisions de restructuration qu'il faut
fermer des usines c'est plus facile
fermer une usine qui est très très loin
du centre de décision qu'une usine qui
est prêt d'autoriser c'est l'éléphant
dans la pièce on en parle pas beaucoup
mais ça reste un enjeu et résolu encore
beaucoup beaucoup de retraités
il y a plus de retraités en fait chez
résolu que d'employés donc un fond de
retraite qui est un enjeu encore
important c'est résolu Franck detoury
qui est vraiment un géant du secteur de
la forêt au Québec qui dirigeait thème
bec si je me rappelle bien qui a été
vendu aussi à des intérêts américains et
Dom tard qui a été vendu puis voilà
résolu qui est vendu
donc cette ressource là les intérêts
étrangers ou les entreprises étrangères
en ont de besoin
oui en fait ça fait partie de notre
histoire forestière l'industrie a été
britannique américaine parfois
canadiennes on a eu pas encore puis
québécois qui ont été des joueurs
importants c'est vrai aujourd'hui il
demeure à bec et la propriété de la
famille s'auto et kruga qui sont des
quand même des joueurs importants
québécois et il y a des plus petits
joueurs comme chantier chez bougamo qui
ont acquis l'usine de Quévillon de
porter papier mais si on veut que des
joueurs québécois émergent et se
développe ça prend le support de l'État
et dans le cas il y a pas des intérêts
privés québécois canadiens qui
pourraient les acheter
c'est une transaction énorme le groupe
dom-tire est résolu là c'est le plus
grand joueur au Canada et un des très
grands joueurs en Amérique du Nord donc
ça représente un saut important en
taille par rapport aux investisseurs
québécois si on regarde Kruger ou les
chantiers chez bougamo c'est sûr que ces
gens-là ne pourraient rien faire sans
l'appui de la Caisse de dépôt et
placement du Québec puis on sait que
dans le passé le gouverneur du Québec a
eu l'ambition de créer un joueur de
taille mondiale au Québec et au Canada
par l'entreprise d'eau phare qui a
existé de 1986 à 2002 et ils avaient
investi pour créer ce géant et ils sont
toujours ils ont vendu ce qui était à
l'époque donne eu et d'hommes
effectivement qui faisait partie de
dauphins mais aujourd'hui ils sont
actionnaires puis qui collabore avec
Koga et chantier chez bougamo et
pourraient décider qu'ils jouent un rôle
important s'il y avait un rôle pour des
entreprises québécoises à ce niveau-là
ça pourrait ça serait impossible que ça
soit ça la participation du gouvernement
du Québec puis rebaisse un choix
politique économique absolument Robert
Beauregard c'était très intéressant
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]